I literally live my life based on how
many people are going to show up to my
funeral to compel someone to go to their
funeral you had to have a real impact
yeah unfortunately I've been to a lot of
funerals in the business world and boy I
remember when I was 19 I went to this
one funeral and there was like nine
people there and I was like makes sense
he just was not nice is he laughing like
it was like Honestly though it was very
real to me I was like this guy was
profoundly successful in the liquor
business that I was a part of but he was
just genuinely not kind and I saw it all
manifested right there and I'm like mhm
I'm going to do the reverse of this
yeah and I was such a motherucker I'm
like and I'm going to build a much
bigger business